oh my goodness wow you once said if you
ever die you wanted someone to turn your
tweets into a book so that's what i did
oh my god i said so many witty things so
fast yeah
amy i don't know what to say this is
horrifying what this is way worse than
crying i mean you put so much work into
this i'm completely uncomfortable it
makes me
kind of makes me sick amy there's
something i want you to do right now
burn the book i need you yes it's the
only way to cleanse your childish
sentimentality and become the true you
the one that's really rosa
okay
sure
i mean it does include a very personal
forward i wrote and 75 of my best
archival glue but
yeah this feels good hey never seen you
burning stuff with a bum barrel before
right on
what was in there hitchcock
first rule of the bum barrel
never ask somebody what they're burning
well okay then
all right amy it's time put the book in
the barrel let's go
no
i can't do it what i thought you wanted
us to change you i thought i did too but
i don't i like having emotions okay this
is who i am
you're leaving and that's a really big
change and i'm gonna cry about it a lot
okay and there it is another flawless
gina moment what what's going on amy the
lesson i wanted to leave you with is to
just be yourself if you want to cry like
an idiot for hours on end just do it you
want to make a big old ugly book full of
all my brilliant thoughts do it
do you
it's gina
oh wow
that was really really sweet oh dip i
got rosa to feel her feelings too
inadvertent gina moment two for one
come in my babies come in
sorry to interrupt ladies but you might
want to take a couple of steps back this
is not going to smell good
it's kind of cool high ceilings so many
windows gina the toilet is in the middle
of the living room
i think it's sexy
should we turn some lights on trying to
save electricity gina your massage chair
is on yeah i'm poor i'm not a savage man
what am i gonna do
but what if i bought this apartment
what are you talking about and then i
could rent it to you till you find a new
place what
how could you afford this place have you
been dealing drugs no i'm thrifty i cut
my own hair i walk to work i eat
scully's lunch every day i've rented the
same crap box since i was 20 cause it's
so cheap i've saved up money and i'm
looking for a real estate opportunity ew
a real estate opportunity are you being
serious we were drinking 40s this
morning i'm saying i could give you a
fair rent because i would be your
landlady whoa whoa you be my landlady
you're gina your lifelong dream is to be
on wife swap you call gum the dentist
you think ray j is a national treasure
yeah so what i'm eclectic you're not
better than me okay
and i'm glad that i still own this place
because i can happily invite you to
leave
grow up jake grow up jake oh my goodness
yeah thanks for your help
old school styles
i take back the z
ames gina
you got to see the sasquatch was it
everything you dreamt it was the stuff
drums are made of can you hold my eyes
still till things stop spinning okay
let's set you up air easy there oh there
you go now drink this entire glass of
water
you're taking care of me just cause i
know you won't remember it
nope
you like me six drink amy is your friend
and and she's gonna be very sick right
now okay
hey what are you doing in here old
scanner was making me anxious so i came
in here to listen to some calming music
it's me singing a song i wrote
subway girl
getting all the looks
holding onto your
big pile of books yeah
listen i was thinking rosa seemed pretty
annoyed about the broken toilet up here
and since she's having a rough day i
thought it would be nice if we got it
fixed for her before she got back and
you came to me cause i'm the only one
who ever gets anything done around here
and because you were supposed to get it
fixed last week so this is kind of a
second chance for you this is a time of
crisis so we're supposed to be lifting
each other up now why don't you call
that plumber i've been asking you to
call for a few hours now
yeah so this won't be a problem i can
pencil you in tomorrow oh uh we kind of
need you to fix it before our friend
gets back today i'm sorry it's gonna
take a while and have other appointments
well can you cancel them i didn't want
to do this but our friend is a cop and
she's caught in the brooklyn heights
shooting right now oh so you think of
the first people that ever needed toilet
fix because a loved one's life was in
danger
yes you're not welcome to new york wow
that's a grim commentary on the city we
live in jake we need to talk yeah you
guys do need to talk that sounds
excellent friendship so much history i'm
just gonna get this out of your way
oh man
what the hell gina you ruined my entire
senior year how could you do that to me
jake i was only trying to help you were
hanging out with those guys and getting
close and they weren't good people do
you know why brandon wasn't at the
reunion tonight i don't know probably
because he was shooting a beer
commercial where the whole plot was that
everyone wanted to sleep with him no
cause he's on parole he's not allowed to
leave the state of delaware oh okay so
that's obviously a bummer but i wasn't
gonna end up like him you were starting
to you wanted to steal a van with them
and i told you not to and you weren't
listening to me i mean what would have
happened if you got caught
i don't know you would never have become
a cop yeah i'm the reason you're a cop
i'm your origin story dude you can't be
mad at me i feel like i'm still pretty
mad peter parker wasn't mad at his
spider yeah but they weren't best
friends before the bite and it still
doesn't explain how you let everyone
think i was the tattler for 20 years
well i didn't want to lose our
friendship i was being weak i'm sorry
okay and if it makes you feel any better
that app thing completely blew up in my
face i mean my night sucked
okay i can see from your expression that
your night was worse and should have
left it at sorry this is when the boyles
went to that farm and we all got hoof
and mouth disease
ah we went to that water park and we all
got hoof and mouth disease again that
was a good vacation sam tina what are
you doing here gina called us what why
because i wanted to show you this it's a
new mother dough now i know it's not 140
years old but i will feed it and i will
nurture it and it will grow and
eventually it'll be just as sour and
smelly as the old one what about the
tang it will be tang town tang town now
can you just let charles back into the
family please how will we get to this
new mother dough you can all come by my
apartment and take a little piece
whenever you want we need keys why in
case you're not home or in the bath gina
it's okay you don't have to do this yes
i do
cause you're my brother
isn't she great we used to have sex you
know
cool
you don't have to mention that every
time you idiot excuse me i have an
announcement to make can i have
everyone's attention please
charles boyle and i had sex what the
hell gina
what are you doing amy was right people
will be shocked and then they'll get
over it and we can move on at least this
way i get to control how it gets out i'm
about to olivia pope this sich first off
i would like to remind you all about
several notable men from my past the
rock climbing backpacker the underwear
model the guy who looked like tywin
lannister i bring these men to mind so
you can appreciate this dahlias for what
it was an outlier i will now take
questions how was the sex gross the sex
was gross or i'm gross you're gross the
sex was adequate how many times did you
do it 16 and a third don't ask can't
explain i have a question
do you have any regrets
no
it was pretty fun
thank you so much for coming out today
you